audio check one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten audio
check one two three okay
okay
um
so
maybe
yes
oh
everything's clean
thank you
dave
is
um
all the
what i way
yep
so
me
so
okay
okay
all right
what's up
i'm so tired
thank you
uh
thank you so much
all right
um
as we
and jacob president
great thanks
good
okay
okay
okay
yes
okay
okay
um
like
okay
so
decorations
it's got its own nest out
job
uh
literally 62 degrees
oh
they're probably tiring
oh
it's just an elephant in the frame
great
um
two minute warning
hey
uh
okay
cheers
thank you very much
today my administration has taken a
momentous step toward
achieving american pharmaceutical
independence
very very big big step
a focus of our campaign to bring
america's
critical supply chains and medical
manufacturing back to the usa we've been
working on this for a long time
this is a core of our strategy to
protect our people from
the horrible china virus should it never
happen
should have never been here they should
have stopped it
in the decades before i took office
foreign nations were allowed to freely
plunder our factories and loot our
industries take our business out of the
united states
millions of jobs were vacuumed out
just taken out so easily our politicians
let that happen
and our communities were stripped
and shipped in many cases to china and
all over the world countries all over
the world
nearly four years ago we launched a bold
effort to revitalize american
manufacturing and act
fair trade deals and bring our
industries back home where they belong
when the china virus landed on our
shores it became clearer than
ever before that restoring american
manufacturing
is a core matter of national security
we must never be reliant on a foreign
nation for america's
medical or other needs and that includes
many other needs
i just want to say that pfizer just
announced
a little while ago that they're
combining phase two
and phase three trials
and the vaccine looks like it's really
heading in a very rapid direction in a
very positive direction
first time that's happened and there are
many months ahead of any other
trial there's never been anything like
it so it's the fastest ever
and to me it's very exciting today i'm
proud to announce one of the most
important deals in the history of u.s
pharmaceutical
industries my administration has reached
a historic agreement
with a great american company you
remember this company it's called
from the good old camera age the old
days
to begin producing critical
pharmaceutical ingredients it's called
kodak
and it's going to be right here in
america so i want to congratulate the
people in kodak they've been
working very hard members of my
administration
are present in rochester right now
rochester new york good place
and they're trying to finalize this
groundbreaking deal and they will be
announcing this deal i want to thank
governor andrew cuomo and his
representatives we've worked really well
together on this deal it's a big deal
it's got a great deal and a great deal
for new york and a great deal for
kodak 90 of all prescriptions written in
the united states are for
generic drugs we have been proved more
generic drugs than any other
administration by far
generic drugs can be just as good as the
brand names
but cost much less yet in less than 10
of the active pharmaceutical ingredients
needed to make these drugs
they're currently manufactured in
america more than 50 percent
however are made in india and china
and you'll be seeing a lot of things
have happened it's been happening
but it's happening at a more rapid pace
right now
with this new agreement my
administration is using the defense
production act to provide a
765 million dollar loan
to support the launch of kodak
pharmaceuticals
it's a great name when you think of it
such a great name was one of the great
brands in the world
then people went digital and kodak
didn't follow
but now under very extraordinary
leadership they are following
and they're doing something that's a
different field and it's a field that
they've really hired some of the best
people in the world to be
taking care of that company and watching
that company watching over it
but it's a breakthrough in bringing
pharmaceutical manufacturing back to the
united states
under this contract our 33rd use of the
defense production act remember
when you were saying i didn't use it
enough i didn't use it enough
then now you heard it's the 33rd use we
don't talk about it all the time we used
it and we used it as a
little bit of a threat frankly with
certain companies that weren't doing as
we were asking them to do
and it came through as both a threat and
a usage but
this is a 33rd use of the defense
production act
kodak will now produce generic active
pharmaceutical ingredients
which is a big deal using advanced
manufacturing techniques kodak will also
make
the key starting materials that are the
building blocks for many drugs
in a manner that is both cost
competitive and environmentally safe
will be competitive with almost all
countries and soon with all countries
once this new division is fully
operational in addition to all of the
other plants that
we've opened with other companies
throughout the united states recently
it will produce as much as 25 of all
active ingredients needed to make
generic drugs in the usa it's a big
number
25 percent this agreement will
directly create 360 new jobs at kodak's
factory in rochester that's just in the
initial phase
and in minneapolis a place i have gotten
to know very well and it's a great place
and i'm very happy that we're able to
help them with the problems that they've
had
recently the national guard i want to
thank the national guard
both state and beyond i want to thank
them for the incredible job they went in
and they did some beautiful job they
cleaned it up you didn't hear about the
problems anymore
and indirectly i want to create we
created thousands more jobs all across
our
pharmaceutical supply chains we have
now been building a very big
pharmaceutical supply chain
not only coming out of china coming out
of other countries also
i want to thank peter navarro adam
bowler and admiral polovcheck
for their tremendous work to make this
deal possible
today's action is our latest step to
build the greatest medical arsenal in
history we'll be able to do that
through the defense production act and
other authorities we have
invested more than three billion dollars
in our nation's industrial base
we've contracted with companies such as
ford
general motors phillips and general
electric to produce more than
200 000 ventilators by the end of this
year
nearly seven times more than we would
ever do in a typical year
we've contracted with honeywell 3m
o m helyart moldex and lydal
to increase u.s production of n95 masks
and
we've brought it from less than 40
million a month to over a hundred
million a month
by august and we'll have 160 million
in a very short while 160 million a
month
that's many times what we used to do if
you go back two years ago
many many times we're increasing
domestic production of gloves
by one thousand percent it's one
thousand percent
we will be manufacturing 450 million
gloves annually by next year
we're finalizing contracts with our
textile industry to make gowns in
america with
american fabric which makes a lot of our
businesses happy that produce the fabric
we have 13 million reusable gowns in the
stockpile and we'll continue to grow
that number to 72
million this fall which is a rapid
escalation indeed
we made major investments in new rapid
point-of-care tests
so we have a there's nothing like the
rapid point
where you get your answer in five
minutes to 15 minutes to maybe 20-25
minutes at the max
and we're already at about a 50 level
and we're bringing it up very
substantially from there we're growing
domestic production from less than 250
000 test kits per month in may to 8
million
test kits per month there is nothing
like this that has ever taken place
anywhere in the world or close through
our partnership with puritan
manufacturing in the state of maine
great state
we've increased production of test swabs
from 30 million
per month in june to 56 million per
month now as you remember i went to
maine i went to the
plant where they do this it was
incredible as a great experience
and we'll produce over 100 million swabs
per month by january
we've dramatically ramped up production
of materials needed for a vaccine
and earned track to rapidly produce 100
million doses as soon as
a vaccine is approved which could be
very very soon and 500 million
doses shortly thereafter so we'll have
500 million doses
and logistically we're using our
military our great military a
group of people their whole life is
based around logistics and
bringing things to and from locations
and they'll be able to take care of this
locationally and bringing it
where it has to go very very quickly
they're all mobilized it's been fully
set up
a very very talented general is in
charge and
when we have that vaccine it will be
discharged and taken care of it'll be
a very very rapid process all over the
country
and perhaps we'll be supplying a lot of
the vaccine
to other parts of the world like we do
with ventilators and other things that
we
all of a sudden have become very good at
making when the china virus struck our
nation we mobilize the entire government
and the private sector to acquire source
and deliver
life-saving supplies hhs
fema and the private sector combined
have coordinated the delivery of more
than 196 million n95 respirators
815 million surgical masks
20 million gloves 34 million face
shields and 354
million gallons that's a lot of gowns
last week
fema completed a second shipment of
personal protective equipment
to over 15 000 nursing homes in the
united states our big focus has been on
nursing homes and
senior citizens as you know that's where
we want to take care we have to take
care of the most vulnerable
especially if they have a medical
difficulty a medical problem in
particular heart
or diabetes which provided a total of
1.2 million pairs of protective eyewear
14 million mask
masks 66 million pairs of gloves and
13 million gallons we have replenished
the
long neglected national stockpile
in january the stockpile had 17.9
million
n95 masks today the stockpile has over
50 million n95 masks and we'll be
doubling that in a very short period of
time
and then doubling that number we've
shipped more than 14
000 ventilators to areas of need across
the country and we've
more than 75 000 available to deploy
not a single american who has needed a
ventilator
has been denied a ventilator and if you
remember
early on when we were first hit with the
virus
ventilators were very hard to come by
and now we're the largest maker anywhere
in the world by far and
not only are we fully supplied in stock
but we're helping other nations because
ventilators are hard to build and hard
to get
this is just a beginning in the coming
months we will continue the largest
onshoring campaign in american history
we will bring back our jobs and we will
make america the world's premier medical
manufacturer and supplier that's what's
happening already it's been happening
now for
quite some time we're seeing
improvements across the major metro
areas and
most hot spots you can look at large
portions of our country it's
it's corona free but we are
watching very carefully california
arizona texas
and most of florida that's starting to
head down in the right direction
and i think you'll see it rapidly head
down very soon but
if you look california arizona texas and
for the most part most of
florida starting to head down in the
wake of the recent mass gatherings
americans have witnessed in the
streets of portland and seattle we are
also tracking a significant rise in
cases in both metropolitan areas
because of what's been going on and we
as you know have done a excellent job of
watching over portland and watching our
courthouse where they wanted to burn it
down they're anarchists
nothing short of anarchists agitators
and
we have protected it very powerfully and
if we didn't go there i will tell you
you wouldn't have a courthouse you'd
have a
you'd have a billion dollar burned-out
building
we're also working aggressively to
combat the virus in native american and
alaska native communities
under the cares act we provided eight
billion dollars to address the
coronavirus in
tribal communities and we've worked very
hard with tribal communities they're
very
vulnerable to this horrible plague
that's the largest investment in indian
country
in u.s history there's never been an
investment that big in indian country
we need every american to help protect
our fellow citizens and prevent the
spread of the disease
it's critical that younger americans
remember that even though they are at
lower risk and in fact
some are in some age groups are at
extraordinarily low risk
themselves they can unknowingly spread
the virus to others
who are at higher risk i ask all
americans regardless of background or
age to practice social distancing which
people have gotten very used to but we
have to keep doing it
remain vigilant about hygiene avoid
indoor
gatherings and large gatherings but
especially indoor especially
where you have crowded bars and that you
wear a mask
whenever appropriate through the genius
of our scientists the devotion of our
doctors the skill of our workers and the
dedication of our people
we will achieve victory over the virus
and emerge stronger than ever before
we're looking at a very powerful year
next year economically
the job numbers are looking outstanding
to put it mildly set records
the numbers on retail retail sales
came in two weeks ago at the highest
number in the history of our country so
we look like we're heading to some very
very good economic times that means jobs
that means stock market stock market is
already doing very well it's getting to
a point very close to where it was
when we had this uh when we were hit
with the
the plague so i just want to thank
everybody for being here
uh steve please go ahead can you clarify
uh your acceptance speech for the
republican nomination
are you physically going to be in
charlotte or we give the speech here
somewhere else
we'll be doing a speech uh on thursday
the main speech the primary speech
charlotte they will be doing nominating
on monday that's a different
that's a different period a different
thing happening but they'll be doing
nominations
on monday uh i speak on thursday
okay from where we'll go we'll be
announcing it soon
oh so you could be going to sharp
anybody have any ideas
we'll be announcing it very soon
mr president um the negotiations are
ongoing right now
for the next relief measures republican
senate republicans have put forth their
plan
do you support what senate republicans
have put forward and are there certain
aspects that they have put forward that
you don't support
yeah there are actually and we'll be
talking about it there are
you know also things that i very much
support um
but we'll be negotiating it's sort of
semi-irrelevant because the democrats
come
with their needs and asks and the
republicans go with theirs
so we'll be discussing it with mitch and
all of the other people involved kevin's
been very active as you know
uh all of the people involved steve
mnuchin's done a great job
keeps everybody together both democrat
and republican
and we'll see we want to do what's best
for the people i want to do what's best
for the people
i want to do what's best for the economy
because that means jobs and lots of good
things all right
senate republicans sir
mr president two questions quickly first
can you clarify your position
on the efficacy of hydroxychloroquine
after
you retweeted a video of making claims
that it is the it's
recommendations of many other peoples
and people including doctors
many doctors think it is extremely
successful
the hydroxychloroquine coupled with the
zinc
and perhaps the zithromycin
but many doctors think it's extremely
good
and some people don't some people i
think it's become very political
uh i happen to believe in it i would
take it as you know i took it for a
14-day period
and i'm here right i'm here
uh i happen to think it's uh it works in
the early stages
i think frontline medical people believe
that too
some many and so we'll take a look at it
but
the one thing we know it's been out for
a long time that particular
formula and that's what essentially what
it is the pill
and it's been for malaria lupus and
other things
uh it uh it's safe it doesn't cause
problems i had no problem i had
absolutely no problem felt no different
didn't feel good bad or indifferent and
i tested as you know it didn't
it didn't get me and it's not going to
hopefully hurt anybody so we know from
that stanford
because it's been so many years from a
safety standpoint it's safe
i happen to think based on what i've
read i've read a lot
about hydroxy i happen to think that it
has an impact especially at the earlier
years there were some very good tests at
ford and the doctor from yale came up
with a very very strong
testament to it there was a group of
doctors yesterday a large group that
were put on the internet and for some
reason the internet wanted to take them
down
and uh took them off i guess twitter
took them off and
i think facebook took them off i don't
know why i think they're very respected
doctors
there was a a woman who was spectacular
in her
statements about it that she's had
tremendous success with it
and they took her they took her voice
off i don't know why they took her off
but they took her off maybe they had a
good reason maybe they didn't i don't
know
i can only say that from my standpoint
uh
and based on a lot of reading and a lot
of knowledge about it
i think it could have a very positive
impact
in the early stages and i don't think
you lose anything by doing it
other than politically it doesn't seem
to be too popular you know why
because i recommend it when i recommend
something
they like to say don't use it john
please on that note mr president last
night
in tweets that were deleted by twitter
uh you said that dr fauci
misled the country about
hydroxychloroquine how so
no not at all i think i don't even know
what his stance is on it i
i was just you know he was at the uh he
was at the task force meeting a little
while ago
uh i have a very good relationship with
dr fauci you know it's sort of
interesting we've listened to dr fouch i
haven't always agreed with him and
that's i think
pretty standard that's okay uh he did
not want us to
ban our this this put up the ban to
china
when china was heavily infected very
badly wuhan
he didn't want to do that and i did and
other things and he told me i was right
and he told me i saved
tens of thousands of lives which was
generous but it's
you know i think it's fact then i banned
i did the ban on europe
uh but i get along with him very well
and i agree with a lot of what he said
uh so you know it's interesting uh
he's got a very good approval rating and
i like that it's good
because remember he's working for this
administration he's working with us
john we we could have gotten other
people we could have
gotten somebody else it didn't have to
be dr fatchi he's working with our
administration and for the most part
we've done pretty much what he and
others dr burks and others who are
terrific
recommended and he's got this high
approval rating so
why don't i have a high approval rating
with respect and the administration
with respect to the virus we should have
a very high because
what we've done in terms of we're just
reading off about the masks and the
gowns and the ventilators and
numbers that nobody's seen and the
testing at 55 million tests we tested
more than anybody in the world i have a
graph that i'd love to show you i'm
perhaps you've seen it where we're up
here and the rest of the world is down
at a level
that's just a tiny fraction of what
we've done in terms of testing
so it sort of is curious a man works for
us with us very closely dr fauci and dr
burks
also highly thought of and yet
they're highly thought of but nobody
likes me it can only be my personality
that's all go ahead can i just ask you
also uh dhs announced today that it is
going to undertake a thorough review of
the daca program to decide whether to
continue it and if not
how to dispense you after the supreme
court uh
ruling about daca that you were thinking
about a path to citizenship
for daca recipients are you still
thinking we're going to work with a lot
of people on daca and we're also working
on an immigration bill a merit-based
system which is what i've wanted for a
long time
that decision was an interesting
decision because it gave the president
as a president more power than many
people thought the president had so the
president
is now which happens to be me in a
position where i can do
an immigration bill and a health care
bill and some other bills and you've
seen some of them come along
uh we're going to do tremendous if we
just signed it
three days ago we're doing tremendous uh
prescription drug price
reductions tremendous it could be over
50
whether it's uh favored nations clauses
or anything else i mean it's tremendous
numbers we're talking about
you know you go to some countries and
they'll sell like a pill
for 10 cents and in the united states it
costs
two dollars and it's the same basic
factory it's the same everything the
united states bears the cost of all of
these low prices that you see all over
the world where people go to canada
to buy a prescription drug from the
united states
not going to happen with me it's not
going to happen with me so john i think
one of the exciting things got very
little coverage and that's okay but the
people understand it
i think we will be reducing prescription
drug prices by
massive amounts numbers that have never
been done before
other thing in 51 years we got as you
know last year
drug prices came down first time in 51
years
that they came down now with what i
signed last week
i think that drug prices can come down
uh
by numbers like 50 and even greater in
certain instances
where i originally started are you still
considering a path to citizenship for
current doctors
we are going to make daca happy and the
daca people and representatives happy
and we're also going to end up with a
fantastic
merit-based immigration system please
yeah
um uh on the drug pricing you had said
that pharmaceutical representatives
would be here today for a meeting to
talk about bringing drug prices down or
to negotiate
that meeting was cancelled why i didn't
know a meeting was canceled oh
a meeting with the uh drug there would
be a meeting today with drug
companies uh well i said there would be
a meeting yeah
meeting sometime this week yes they want
to meet i mean i don't know that it was
canceled they want to meet
uh i thought the meeting was actually
scheduled for tomorrow
i thought i thought the meeting was
scheduled tomorrow sorry about the dates
but you know
i see how upset you are by it go ahead
please mr bloomberg you look like mr
bloomberg go ahead
thank you mr president would you support
a temporary extension of uh supplemental
unemployment aid if uh the deal that
they're having got in congress isn't
completed by the end of this week
we're going to take care of the people
yeah it's a good question we're going to
take care of the people
the woman that you said was a great
doctor and that video that you retweeted
last night
said that masks don't work and there is
a cure for covid19
both of which health experts say is not
true she's also made videos saying that
doctors make medicine using dna from
aliens and that they're trying to create
a vaccine to make you
immune from becoming religious maybe
it's a sign maybe it's not but
i can't i can tell you this she was on
air
along with many other doctors they were
big fans of
hydroxy chloroquine and i thought she
was very impressive
in the sense that from where she came i
don't know which country she comes from
but she said that she's had tremendous
success with hundreds of different
patients
and i thought her voice was an important
voice but i know nothing about her
last week real quick thank you very much
everybody
thank you
get you in trouble
i